frage ja es wird sich auch nie ändern
wird sich nie ändern
die lage ist gut album ist draußen ich
mache viel promotion fühle mich gut und
glas single die glaube ich auf markung
war die erfolgreichste single die du je
gehabt hast stimmt das ja auf 12 glaube
ich ein rennen geliefert im radio rauf
und runter läuft immer noch auf und hat
immer noch auf den 5 ich werde nicht so
viel radio muss ich sagen happy absolut
vor allem fenster immer wieder bei null
an
jedes mal wenn du irgendwas neues machst
du erschaffst fängt wieder bei null an
und auch gerade single auskopplungen es
ist immer so ein thema wo ich mich auch
mal ein bisschen schwierig mit tue weil
für mich ist jeder song auf dem album
die single muss es dann einfach so das
erste zeichen vom album zumal die single
ja nicht unbedingt auf das album
repräsentieren weil das album auch
wieder sehr verschieden ist von den
inhalten her und es hätte so alles
passieren können
also es war für mich auch so ein
bisschen so ein ding entweder es
funktioniert gut das funktioniert gar
nichts und da gab's nichts dazwischen
bei der single auswahl die von der
plattenfirma kam bei mir war egal was
ihr zuerst ausgepowerte egal weil dir an
jedem song wahnsinnig viel liegt oder du
bringst du saufen tun
na ja das weiß ich nicht jeder song hat
seine geschichte und jeder song ist für
mich eine single ist es wert
ausgekoppelt zu werden und auch jetzt
bei dem album you the doors ist so dass
wir auch recht viele songs aus koppeln
sich auch das letzte album kam vor drei
jahren pause hat sich viel verändert
auch was videodreh ist angelegt war vor
zwei wochen in jamaika und habe in neun
tagen fünf videos gedreht
es geht einfach heute viel mehr um
content also zweifel bis zum bestimmten
punkt sind sind gut und auch gesund und
ab einem bestimmten punkt wenn sie dann
zu intensiv werden dann wird es
irgendwann nehmen und das hatte ich auch
schon ich meine einfach so dieses ding
das was ich mache ist es gut so ich
finde jetzt nicht dass ich ein toller
sänger bin zum beispiel also mein range
ist sehr limitiert
sondern was findest du ich weiß nicht
ich glaube einfach so
das heißt ich glaube ich habe einfach
bock darauf dass zu machen
aber es gibt ja so das was die leute
auch glaube ich fühlen deswegen ist es
auch schon so lange jetzt aber ich habe
ja auf den gedanken sich irgendwann das
gefühl boxing gedanken so irgendwann
finden die leute raus dass ich
eigentlich gar nichts kann so und das
habe ich immer schon gehabt und dann
gibt es aber momente wo ich denke so war
uns auch ich bin doch ein guter
entertainer kann auch gutes songs machen
aber bei memories zum beispiel seinem
tod von einem freund ist das dann für
dich also ist das quasi muss so ein song
zu machen um das zu verarbeiten ist
überhaupt gar kein muss musik zu machen
aber es ist ein wunderschöner weg
einfach auch besser klarzukommen mit
bestimmten situationen und gerade der
song memories war einfach für mich mehr
als therapie so ja ich dann einfach mit
dem song als der song dann da war und
auch diese magie da war das war dann
irgendwie der moment wo ich auch viel
besser mit der situation umgehen konnte
und wo die trauer dann somit sind auch
in dankbarkeit umgeschwenkt ist das ist
einfach einfach froh war dass dieser
mensch existiert nicht mehr dieses klar
diese lehre die es immer da auch so aber
es ist einfach ein teil vom leben
ich glaube wir werden ja immer öfter
damit konfrontiert und auch gerade jetzt
in meinem bekanntenkreis oder familie
freundeskreis ist es immer öfter das
irgendwie ein elternteil auf einmal
nicht mehr da ist mein freund oder
bekannter oder jemand aus der familie
das ist einfach ein thema womit wir uns
auch finde ich viel mehr beschäftigen
sollten
der tod an es wird immer so tabuisiert
in unserer gesellschaft
ich habe auch mit demjenigen von dem der
song handelt immer auch über den tod
gesprochen
finde auch dass es die einzige
gerechtigkeit ist es gibt ja weil alle
menschen irgendwann gehen können und
müssen auch nicht von dieser highlander
vision immer größer wir werden ewig
leben ich weiß nicht also dadurch
christi auch ein ganz anderes bild aufs
leben und ganz viel intensiver leben und
auch viel mehr wertschätzen
absolut also ich muss immer sagen der
tod ist ein hervorragender ratgeber der
sagte nämlich dass man jeden tag auf 7
das beste machen ich habe irgendwann so
ein spruch gelesen in der wand in berlin
tot nimmt sich einen tag nach dem
anderen zu helfen ist inzwischen das
leben wäre das absolut